you also have an interrogation process
for writers with the traffic technique
right and it's entitled meet your
characters that's part of it because you
start out saying an interrogation
process for writers which with there are
a lot of techniques within that and the
interrogation process just to be clear
about what it is is actually
interrogating a character who lives
inside an actor or an individual so this
interrogation process which can ignite
characters inside the actors we use this
with writers and we show writers how to
do this to actually meet their
characters either what after they've a
written the screenplay while they're
writing the screenplay often we've done
it they even have an idea for a
screenplay and they say we get a call
say I'd like to do meet your characters
can you help me meet the characters that
I have and so the writer will then
describe to us two else you and I hear
that here's the story here are the
characters we say fine we'll gather
together some actors who are very
skilled actors who we've worked with
before and what we will do with these
actors is we will give them along with
the writers understanding of what we're
doing a certain amount of information
about these characters sometimes it's
very little information sometimes it's a
lot of information all depends on how
developed the writer has gone how far
they've gone in the development of the
characters and we will interrogate these
actors as these characters so we will
turn these actors into these characters
that's the intent and then we will put
actually put these characters together
we'll have them interact we will have
the show the writer how not only how to
do the interrogation but allowed the
writer to actually engage with the
characters so let's say this three or
four characters that we've interrogated
and they're all the characters now all
these actors have become the characters
and now the writer can end
with the characters and ask them
questions and interrogate them and start
to learn - he will actually meet his
characters sometimes the writer says
we'll say those I have this idea for a
scene I want between the husband and
wife say great great we'll do that
during the interrogation it will
interrogate the husband and wife and
we'll put them into that scene now there
is no scene there's nothing written but
it's a scene maybe when he comes home
and he discovers that she bought the red
dress that he told her she couldn't buy
or something like that and he discovers
that she bought it and that's they have
a little in very little information but
enough information for a scene this is
important for a scene to get started
that's all there's no more information
beyond that there's no information about
what the father and the husband or the
wife say or do and there's no
information about how the scene ends
it's just enough to get them into the
scene because the important thing about
interrogation is once we interrogate an
actor as the character that character
knows nothing about the script or the
story nothing now the actor may know a
lot but the character knows nothing the
character is totally naive so we can
send those characters into a scene just
enough to get the scenes started and see
what happens and now the writer is
sitting there watching and interaction
between two of his characters happen
something he hasn't even written yet do
we try that now with something we can we
can try that and in keep in mind I'm not
a professional writer here so there's
gonna be a very very light story so my
character that I've come with up with is
her name is Jill she's 26 years old
she's unmarried and she has a seventh
month old baby with a man named Jack so
because of some life issues Jill and
Jack have lost their right to stay at
Jill's grandmother's home they were all
living and then after being kicked out
of there they move into Jack's brother's
home and Jack's brothers kind of several
steps up he has a stable job and a
family life but before you know it Jill
and Jack are
again asked to leave and they have with
their baby baby Maya so now they've been
asked to leave two places um so before
Jill fell into this situation she plan
on going to chef school and she was
always artistic this situation mean
pregnancy and meeting Jack I think Jack
came before the pregnancy that's it was
an immaculate conception yeah no no but
you said this situation before she got
into this relationship this relationship
right yeah and and then this baby and
then being bounced around from these
different she wanted to go to she wanted
to be a chef yeah she wanted to be a
chef and she was very artistic and
unfortunately some of her demons got the
better of her and she met Jack while
attending night school for this this
chef sort of career and they both fell
into the world of partying and it got
the better of them so now here they are
they've been kicked out of their second
place with a seventh month old baby and
I want to get to know Jill better okay
and this camera is your creation is this
character is your creation
yeah just for the sake of this interview
ya know it's not like I'm writing
something yeah it's your creation didn't
come from something else
no no just Jack and Jill or you know
those are those are use elsewhere but
yeah so now you want to meet that
character yeah character okay that's
fine so I need to talk to Jill okay okay
do you want me to be jmi Jill or this is
where Jill Jill lives inside you okay so
I need to talk to Jill okay okay Joey
yes I work how old are you I'm 26 26 and
you wanted to be a chef I do you still
want to be a chef I do I love The
Cooking Channel
I love me other things yeah making food
into pastries or cakes or casseroles or
salad what kind of what kind of chef do
you want to be an assortment maybe less
with meat more vegetarian more
vegetarian yeah but you love cooking
mm-hmm so you could but you but you're
you're married now are you oh you're not
married but you have a child correct
okay but you still pursuing being a chef
um I don't know how I'm gonna balance I
don't know I mean I wanted to watch her
but he he want him to watch you want
Jack to watch your child but he won't
I mean he's notice and what is he doing
he's not reliable what is he doing is he
working now right now he was he's not
working he was and are you working now
not right now and in order to pursue
being a chef what do you have to do well
I need to go back and finish these other
credits there's a couple classes I
didn't finish oh you got a couple
classes you have to finish and then you
get a certificate or a degree or
something right and then I want to be
accepted into this other like more
professional chef school okay and then
to move on to a more professional school
so you got a plan that's it I mean this
is a plan I Maya wasn't planned I didn't
say that it doesn't mean I don't love in
terms of cheffing being a chef you have
a plan right the gut that sort of got
interrupted a little bit a little bit
you know that happens yeah it happens to
a lot of people so what are you gonna
get start getting you know working on
these credits well I need like my
grandmother was paying for it and then
this Jack loved you in his own way what
does that mean here's a weird his his
own way of loving work what is it he has
like trust issues trust trusting we both
do it's not just him I have trust issues
can you trust him not with money no not
with money I mean he you want to marry
him if he if he stops drinking I do if
he stopped oh he's got a drinking
problem yeah he's gonna drinking problem
he doesn't have a job you can't trust
him why with the he's a good guy
he's a good guy for what does he watch
after me does he want you to go back to
chef school I think he gets jealous does
he want you to go back to chef school
he's jealous I'm gonna meet someone
there oh no he's jealous you're gonna
meet someone so he wants to keep you at
home cuz he saw my instructor and I were
working and he just said like I don't
like the way you stare at him
and he stares at you is that why he was
so excited when you got pregnant I know
how excited he was is that his way of
keeping you at home Jill why does he
want to keep you at home he's not doing
anything when you were at home with me
Oh where's Jack he's watching TV he's
watching TV he needs his time to watch
sports and drink and and just be like is
that what he says or is that what you
say well I want to respect him and his
wishes Jill do you respect him and his
wishes to stay home and watch TV and
drink beer with his friends say what he
does no I mean I I mean yeah that's what
he does but I don't why were you kicked
out of the house we got some fights with
who well he got mad at my grandmother
and my grandmother said that he took
some money from from her I don't think
he did I think it was somebody else but
she blames you think he could have maybe
you think he was capable of that yeah
but I I don't she doesn't like him and
so anything he does like she just
automatically wants to blame them yep
and who during that argument between
your grandmother and Jack right mm-hmm
what did you say well I don't did you
defend Jill I get to defend Jack I asked
him to keep his voice he yells at her
and I don't like messes keeping his
voice down that's not the issue the
issue is she accused him of stealing
some money and she's gonna kick him out
of the house who are you defending I was
defending him why he's just had it rough
and so oh so what stop you have to take
care of him you have to protect him now
you have two children Jill you have two
children one's only a few months old the
other ones in this 20s or something
is this the way the rest of your life is
gonna go do you love your grandma I know
you do you love her grandmother yes
I do she's believed in me when I was
always good to you yes she took you in
when you needed help when you got
pregnant and you didn't know where to go
she protected you and then you protected
him against her if you left Jack with
Mia could you go back to live with your
grandmother she says she won't give me
any more money I didn't ask you that
could you live with her baby would she
watch Mia she loves me yeah she's been
she's been willing to watch her but she
doesn't like his drinking so she doesn't
know I didn't say him he's not going
back you're going back with Mia would
she let you live with her
you and Mia but then he'll just be gone
I know he'll be gone woody is not answer
would she let you live with her would
she watch Mia for you would she let you
go back to school would she support you
the way Jack doesn't what do you want
you I just want us all to be happy the
three of us well that's great everybody
wants that what are you gonna do but I
think that with the right time he can be
better right time for what just if he
just needs someone to believe in him no
one believed in him and so he needs
people to believe in him no one believes
in it so I believe in his words your job
to believe in him and do you believe in
him if he could just know do you believe
in him it's easy to say you believe in
someone if they stopped all the horrible
things they're doing anybody can say
that do you believe in him now having
not stopped anything he's still drinking
he still doesn't trust you he's horrible
with money he's not gonna support you
he's not gonna watch the child for you
to go back to school he's not doing any
of that do you believe in it he's do you
want to be at least was that he's in
place right now he certainly is do you
believe in him do you want to be with
him Jill I believe in who do you want to
be what I do want to be with him why
because we you know things were better
before like you know his current
behavior and he just had more he was
just fun and and I think that he just
needs some time to to become a better
person you know he didn't have a lot of
role models growing up and I know that's
I can't like use as an excuse but I just
think that if someone believes in him he
will turn it around if someone and that
someone happens to be you but you don't
believe in him some days it's clear that
you don't believe in some days I do know
some days oh that's great how about a
hundred percent believe in him 100% love
him 100% support him he changes when he
drinks okay I got it so he says he just
wants to have a beer every now and then
and watch if you could wave a back magic
wand what would you ask for that we
would get married and that he would stop
drinking and that we both get jobs and
we wouldn't have to rely on my
grandmother that you would get married
yeah does he want to get married he says
one day what's that he's one day I mean
his parents weren't married so what so
and it doesn't mean anything so he
doesn't believe in the institution of
marriage
I see so he really doesn't want to get
married but you want to get married yeah
does he want to get a job that was part
of the magic wand thing is that he got a
job does he want to get a job have you
ever heard him talk about a job that he
really wants and that he's willing to go
for it what does he want to do besides
sit home and drink and watch TV
like I said he's just in a bad place
right now and then if we could just get
him in a better place than Jill you
living with a parasite you know that
he's gonna suck everything out of you
everything all your energy all your joy
all your talent all your hopes all your
dreams but I told you sucked dry and
then he'll probably leave you but I
don't want me to grow up without a
father I want her to have him there
I mean I I know he's not perfect I'm not
perfect I'm not perfect so I can't
expect him to be perfect you can expect
expect him to be better than he is you
can expect him to respect you you can
expect him to love you you can expect
him to support you you can expect him to
sacrifice things that are important to
him to help you if it's a marriage just
being married won't make it any better
you know that it'll be just the same as
it is now well he says he loves ya I'm
sure he does I'm sure he does do you
love me absolutely do you want her to
grow up with a father like that just
because he's the biological father he's
the only choice I just don't want to do
that to her do what to it I don't want
her to not know who raised her I mean
like who her dad was I don't want her
knowing she could know him like question
mark she could know him how are you
gonna protect me I know one day she'll
be strong and she'll see that he does
love her he's just going through some he
just he's not perfect he has issues but
I'm not perfect either so I can't
totally just expect him to be perfect
you know he says that I nag him all the
time and that I'm always on this case
okay she's so you so you're going to
hang in there yeah I thought about maybe
moving back to migrators with me and
then but I don't know where he's gonna
go so but do it you can do that move
back with your grandmother you're a
beautiful strong vibrant young woman who
wants to be a chef you have everything
in front of you you can make any choice
you want to make just make it there's
nothing stopping you but what's gonna
happen to him he doesn't have anywhere
to go
who knows that's his problem I just
don't want him to become more
self-destructive than he already is and
they happened but it won't be your fault
he's a great father isn't he
like I said when he's in a good place a
good place is a great father seems like
it I mean and you're happy when he's a
great father right when he's a good
place yeah so stay with him just stay
with him maybe it'll work out
who knows he just he doesn't like it
when I like not that I'm not telling
where I'm going and he wants to like
know like where I am all the time and so
it's just hard for me to like have a
life and then he's there and I you know
if you could tell Jack anything you
wanted without fear of what would happen
anything what would you tell him I just
want to see him be better and believe in
himself and just he doesn't need to
always have like a beer it seems like
every hour with that's what you want to
tell him I just I want to see him like
be the person I know he can be what do
you really think of him I think that he
just never had anyone believe in him but
I see it don't know what do you think of
him what do you Joe think of Jack
I don't know he's become so negative I'm
gonna ask you one last question if you
had to do it had it to do all over again
would you have gotten involved with jack
no no I would have stayed at the school
and just okay kept going okay now we're
gonna stop okay
so what was that like painful painful I
feel bad for Jill okay
she's stuck you know and um you know she
doesn't have any resources and she's
relying on this grandmother and you know
maybe Jack's a good guy but she's not
that's not her fault it's not she can't
fix him but um she's like stuck in this
pit and you're right she's taking care
of two children and I guess I wanted to
have a backbone you want her to have her
back yeah but the since since we did
this because of meat your characters
right and this is not about you Darrin
plain Jill this is about you meeting the
Jill that's existing inside you sure
were there any surprises
how much maybe she made excuses for all
these things or mm-hmm like you brought
them out to light and she just kept like
making excuses for them like if only if
only if only sure in a perfect world but
a perfect world that could just needs
time I mean all the all the excuses that
she makes for him which I don't think
she would make if it wasn't for Mia hmm
that's interesting yeah
that's true because the child changed
everything we're not getting together
with Jack it was the child right changed
everything that changed her perspective
that's true
protecting him protecting him because
you're really protecting her and the
whole thing you want her to have a
father I said well yeah she can have a
father there's more than one out there
that's true there could be the father
but that's because lots of times when we
do this this process with the writer
treating you as the writer of this story
is that the writer will discover things
about their protagonists or any
character in this story that they never
imagined just because it's done through
the interrogation process where the
character is actually speaking no it's
coming from within the writer but it's
because of the way the process works of
the very intense probing questions
that's why it's called interrogation
probing questions about who you are and
there's something unique that I've been
experiencing for years now for both
writers and actors when they go through
this process because they're under the
pressure of the character having to
answer immediately not under the
pressure of oh let me think about that
how journal about that let me think
about let me think about what Jill would
do in that circumstance that that's
can't play at all what plays is Jill's
being asked and you're playing and you
are being Jill and Jill has to answer
and so Jill I'm sure you experienced
that like I have to yeah I Karen can't
stay oh excuse me I don't know the
answer to that can we go on - no there's
no there's no room for that jill has to
answer and so many times you were
surprised by what they comes out of the
character or the character's perspective
or point of view of something and we've
done this many times where writers have
said my god I didn't know he or she
thought that it's amazing no it's not
because of something I do in other words
I'm not injecting information into the
character at all I'm just questioning
the character and the character has to
answer and you're you're free to say
anything you want and aunt you want so
that lets them they're surprised but the
character does exist inside
you because you created that character
and you know the character better than
anybody and all we're doing is moving
you the writer out of the way so you I'm
not allowing you Karen the writer to
control the character you just have to
sit on the side and watch the character
emerge and be questioned and be
interrogated and be herself then you go
wow that's a different person than I
thought I was scared scared
interrogating because I've saw that my
life was like backed into this corner
and that there were no solutions mm-hmm
so and you know it's it's loose I had
thought of a story like this years ago I
never really did much with it but it was
kind of based on people that I would see
that were like young families that kind
of like lived in trailers and different
things and I always wondered like how
did they get there I'm sure this is not
something they planned and you know how
do we know that that couldn't have been
any of us right there with the certain
set of circumstances and so you know
you'll just see someone on the street
and you just like start wondering about
their life mm-hmm and just just yeah I
felt like I think I felt more like Jill
than I ever had I actually had a
different name for the character before
but um we changed it just because it was
so it was a different name it was like
very unusual but I did I felt very
scared and like I had no choices and no
no say no agency in my own life mm-hmm
and so you were showing me as Jill that
like you know there's not many places to
go with this you know so yeah yeah and a
lot of what we do with Jill too is and
this happens a lot of interrogation has
pushed the character up against their
obstacles and it's the obstacles that
are inside them the fears I mean Jill's
fear of not having Jack around which is
really irrational but understandable
understand because that's what happens
but like how yeah because even I said
move back with the grandmother and all
that in you and Mia but you say what's
gonna happen to Jack I don't excuse me
I'm giving you an opportunity to get out
of a bad situation and all you want to
do is get back in it but just to run
into that so we put you know it's it's a
matter of pushing the character up
against even their fears or their denial
or their rationalization or
justification and question it not saying
it's wrong but just can you explain to
me why you think that way that's all I
was doing explain that to me and yeah I
can see you shake it I can't well then
we have a problem that's it okay that's
what was that and that's what we do with
and now there's one other thing that
that process is similar what we do with
writers with the write your life to
accept we're interrogating them as
themselves at a different time but it's
the same process and the same many times
the same thing will happen even they go
wow I didn't know that that's what I was
thinking back then and what happens when
it's with write your life or
autobiographical is and I'm very much
aware of this and I have to be a little
more delicate sometimes because I'm
actually interrogating you as you so I
have to be much more careful I can't be
as aggressive sometimes because but many
times what I'm triggering is the truth
that has been buried and the people are
surprised that this came out and they
they can feel and it's true they can
feel that this is what was really going
on they can feel that this was really
the fears that they were dealing with
and now they go back to look at the
story and they see it in a whole
different way because they see their
protagonist in a different way yeah and
I see this character in a different way
now good
you